Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias
a SurfShark VPN. Luego os doy más
detalles pero antes, vamos
a ver un poco de historia.
Os voy a hacer una pregunta, y seguro
que todos me sabréis responder ¿Cuál es
el país donde se producen más películas
en todo el mundo? Ya sé que lo sabéis:
la respuesta no es Estados Unidos sino la India.
¡Exacto! Todos hemos oído hablar de las películas
de Bollywood aunque seguramente pocos las habréis
visto. Pero la pregunta realmente interesante
es ¿Por qué las películas Indias tienen tanto
éxito? ¿Cómo es posible que Hollywood apenas
haya podido entrar en el mercado Indio? En
casi cualquier país, las películas más vistas
suelen venir de Estados Unidos. Por ejemplo,
en España es muy difícil que una película
española supere en taquilla a las grandes
superproducciones de Hollywood. Y lo mismo ocurre
en casi todos los países… ¡Menos en la India!
Para que os hagáis una idea, en este país, sólo el
13% de los ingresos del cine vienen de películas
extranjeras. El resto es todo producción propia.
¡Y ya sé lo que estará pensando alguno!
Seguramente esto se debe a que la India es un
país gigantesco: el segundo país más grande del
mundo en población ¿verdad? Pues lamento deciros
que os equivocáis. La India puede ser muy grande,
pero también tiene más de 26 idiomas regionales.
De hecho, cuando hablamos de Bollywood,
sólo nos referimos a las películas hechas
en idioma HINDI. Pero eso sólo es un 20%
de toda la industria. El otro 80% va para todos
esos idiomas regionales: Bengalí, Marathi, Tamil y
muchos otros… Sin embargo, pese a todo esto, sólo
en 2019, la India produjo más de 2.200 películas.
El cine Indio es tan importante, que incluso se
ha convertido en todo un arma política. Mirad
lo que llegó a decir el ex primer ministro
indio, Manmohan Singh, sobre el cine Indio:
Cuando voy a Oriente medio o a África, la
gente habla de las películas indias. Esto
es un nuevo modo de mostrar al mundo la creciente
importancia de la india. El poder blando es muy
importante en el nuevo mundo de la diplomacia.
—Manmohan Singh, former Primer Minister of India
El cine indio es tan influyente que bastó una
película para que el turismo de la India hacia
España creciera en un 9,5% en sólo un año. De
hecho, si algún día vais a la fiesta de “La
Tomatina”, en Buñol, seguramente veréis un
montón de Indios. Esto es por una película,
“ZINDAGI NA MILEGI DOBARA”, que habla de unos
chicos Indios que hacen un viaje por España
¡Pero no sólo eso! ¿Sabéis cuál es el canal
de YouTube más grande del mundo? Pues no,
no es PewDewPie… es T-Series: el canal donde se
cuelgan casi todos los videoclips de Bollywood.
Y no os equivoquéis, el cine Indio no
sólo se consume en la India. De hecho,
pese a las malas relaciones entre China y la
India, Bollywood está arrasando en el gigante
asiático. Pero de eso vamos a hablar más adelante.
Antes de seguir voy a hacer una aclaración:
a diferencia de Hollywood, que es un suburbio en
las afueras de Los Ángeles donde están casi todas
las grandes productoras estadounidenses,
Bollywood no existe como tal. Es decir,
no hay ningún lugar llamado Bollywood.
Sin embargo, sí podemos decir que casi
todas las películas en Hindi se producen
en Mumbai, o como se le llamaba antes,
Bombay. Al igual que Los Ángeles, Mumbai es
una ciudad muy próspera, muy cosmopolita y
donde hay buen tiempo todo el año. Por eso
es aquí donde se hacen tantísimas películas.
Pero ahora la pregunta es… ¿Por qué el cine Indio
es tan popular? ¿Cómo afecta la política a esta
industria? ¿Y por qué los Chinos prefieren el
cine de Bollywood al del mismísimo Hollywood?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes… si queréis ver el mejor cine
de Bollywood es probable que no podáis ¿Por qué?
Porque Internet tiene cada vez más restricciones
geográficas. Así que, si queréis acceder a
todos los catálogos completos de Bollywood,
seguramente tengáis que usar una VPN ¿Y cuál es
la VPN favorita de VisualPolitik? ¡Pues claro
que sí! Surfshark VPN. Surfshark es una VPN
fantástica y super segura. Por ejemplo ¿No os
ha pasado alguna vez que entráis en una web y
os salen un montón de ventanitas de publicidad?
Pues eso se llama PHISHING, y por ahí se cuelan
montones de cookies y de virus que se meten en
el móvil o el ordenador. Pues, como ya sabéis
todos, SurfShark tiene una herramienta que se
llama CleanWeb que bloquea todos estos pop ups y
todos estos enlaces que tienen más peligro que un
saco de bombas ¡Pero no sólo eso! Con una única
cuenta de Surfshark podéis registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis: el móvil, la tablet, el
portátil… ¡No hay ningún límite de dispositivos!
Y como siempre, tenemos una oferta muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís VisualPolitik.
Básicamente, si usáis el código “POLITIK”,
tendréis un 83% de descuento… más 3 meses
extra totalmente gratis. Es más, podéis probar
Surfshark durante los primeros 30 días sin ningún
compromiso. En la descripción os dejo los enlaces.
TODO EMPEZÓ CON… ¡JESUCRISTO!
En el año 1911, un señor que se llamaba DADA
SAHEB PHALKE fue con su familia a ver una película
sobre la vida de Jesucristo. Phalke no era
cristiano. Pero recordad que, en aquel momento,
la India era una colonia británica. Las salas de
cine estaban pensadas para los colonos británicos.
Sin embargo, Phalke quedó fascinado al ver
esta película. Y lo primero que le vino a la
cabeza fue hacer una película parecida pero,
en lugar de contar la vida de Jesucristo,
contar historias de la mitología india. Y como
siempre decimos en VisualPolitik… ¡Dicho y hecho!
Phalke se marchó a Londres y aprendió a
hacer películas, después volvió a la India,
buscó el dinero y produjo el primer film Indio
de la historia: RAJA HARISHCHANDRA. Se trataba
de una película muda de 40 minutos sobre un rey
de la mitología hindú. Se proyectó por primera
vez en el Cine Coronation, en Mumbai, en 1913.
Durante los siguientes años, se hicieron muchas
más películas mudas sobre mitología hindú. En 1931
se estrenó la primera película sonora en la india:
ALAM ARA. La gente quedó tan fascinada que
incluso la policía tuvo que ir a algunos
cines de Mumbai para evitar aplastamientos.
Incluso antes de que la India se independizara,
ya hubo una película India que ganó la plama de
oro de Cannes. Esto ocurrió en 1946. A partir de
aquí es cuando empezó lo que podríamos llamar la
era de oro del cine Indio. Películas que hablaban
de los problemas de la clase obrera, la sociedad
post colonial y el día a día de los Indios. En los
años 70 y 80 surgieron nuevos géneros como el cine
de acción o el cine negro. En los 90 encontramos
películas más tradicionales, centradas en valores
familiares y costumbrismo. En otras palabras,
que durante el siglo XX, la India consolidó
toda una industria del cine… Sin embargo,
había un problema. La industria del cine no
estaba reconocida por el Gobierno. Y esto
es muy importante. Recordad que hablamos de la
India, un país extremadamente intervencionista.
No estar en la lista de industrias reconocidas
por el estado significa que las productoras no
podían pedir préstamos a los bancos ni a
ninguna otra institución financiera ¡Ojo!
Esto no significa que hacer películas fuera
ilegal. Pero podríamos decir que estaba en una
situación de “alegalidad”. Estaban marginados
por todo el sistema político y económico ¿Y
qué pasa cuando una industria tiene que operar
fuera del marco institucional? ¿Qué pasa cuando
un sector económico entero está en una posición
de alegalidad? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
LOS GANGSTERS ENTRAN EN LOS ESTUDIOS
En los años 90, el crimen organizado tenía
un peso enorme en Mumbai. Sin embargo,
quitando el tráfico de drogas, el resto de
sus negocios iban de mal en peor. Sin embargo,
Bollywood era una industria muy rentable. A
la vez, las productoras necesitaban cada vez
más dinero para que sus películas pudieran
competir con Hollywood. Y así es como los
gangsters entraron en el mundo del cine. Muchas
de las películas más exitosas de la India,
en aquellos tiempos, estuvieron financiadas
por la mafia. Y, como os podéis imaginar,
hacer negocios con la mafia siempre termina
mal. ¿Queréis un ejemplo? Os doy un ejemplo.
El mafioso dubaití ABU SALEN amenazó al realizador
SUBHASH GHAI por los derechos de distribución en
el extranjero de una de sus películas. En
este caso, la policía consiguió evitar un
intento de los sicarios de Abu Salen. Para que
os hagáis una idea de la gravedad de este asunto,
el tal Abu Salen está ahora mismo condenado
a cadena perpetua porque estuvo envuelto en
el atentado de Mumbai en 1993. Hablamos de un
atentado en el que murieron más de 257 personas.
Otros cineastas como RAKESH ROSHAN, MAHESH BHATT y
BONEY KAPOOR recibieron amenazas de la mafia para
que les dieran parte de sus beneficios. Y hay un
montón de actores que fueron obligados a actuar en
películas financiadas por la mafia. También hay
casos de películas donde los directores estaban
obligados a darle un papel a una de las amantes
del mafioso de turno. Por ejemplo, en 1995,
un director de cine llamado SIDDIQE fue asesinado
porque no quiso darle un papel protagonista a la
amante de un gangster. Para que os hagáis una
idea, la relación entre el cine indio y el
crimen organizado llegó a ser tan importante
que hasta apareció en un papel de Wikileaks.
Se ha filtrado un cable diplomático de
Estados Unidos que dice que Bollywood
aceptó dinero negro de gangsters
y políticos para financiarse
Pero el auténtico punto de inflexión
llegó en 1997 ¿Os acordáis de T-Series,
el canal de YouTube más grande del mundo?
Pues ese canal pertenece a… T-Series,
que es uno de los mayores sellos discográficos y
productoras de la India. Su fundador es GULSHAN
KUMAR. En el año 1997, murió de un disparo
por uno de los narcos más famosos de la India:
DAWOOD IBRAHIM. Ese hombre, por cierto,
también está envuelto en los atentados de
1993. Este asesinato supuso todo un impacto
en la sociedad India. Lo que hasta la fecha
era sólo un secreto a voces, pasó a ser una de
las prioridades de la policía India. Así que,
tras muchas décadas, el Gobierno decidió
cambiar sus políticas sobre el cine.
Bollywood está confuse con su
Nuevo estatus de industria,
pero espera que el negocio
funcione mejor a partir de ahora.
En el año 1998, la industria del cine consiguió,
por fin, el estados de industria formal, tanto a
nivel federal como estatal. Esto provocó un cambio
radical en la forma de financiar las películas.
En el año 2000, la Ley de desarrollo industrial
bancario permitió que las productoras pudieran
recibir préstamos de bancos y de empresas.
Y, de repente, la economía formal empezó a
financiar películas. Por ejemplo, el gigante de
las telecomunicaciones Indias, RELIANCE, o la
productora de Televisión UTV empezaron a producir
películas. Poco a poco, el cine Indio dejó de ser
un negocio peligroso y dejó de depender de las
mafias. No obstante, aún quedan algunos retazos
de ese pasado tan oscuro. Por ejemplo, en 2015,
arrestaron a 10 mafiosos del Clan de RAVI PUJARI
por intento de extorsión al cineasta MAHESH BHATT.
Pero… OK, ya hemos visto cómo el cine Indio se
ha convertido en una industria importante.
Sin embargo, todavía no hemos respondido a
la pregunta más importante de este vídeo.
Tranquilos, ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
¿POR QUÉ EL CINE INDIO ES TAN POPULAR?
Lo hemos dicho al principio: el término Bollywood
se refiere únicamente a las películas en Hindi.
Pero hay muchos otros Bollywoods… y muchas
veces pueden hacer más películas que el
Bollywood original. Por ejemplo, en el
año 2012 se produjeron 262 películas en
Tamil (el idioma que hablan en ciudades como
CHENNAI) y sólo 221 en Hindi. Por ejemplo,
las películas en idioma Telugu están
creciendo un montón en los últimos años.
Sin embargo, todas estas diferentes industrias
del cine tienen algo en común: todas ellas
empezaron a crecer como la espuma cuando el
Gobierno reconoció el cine como una industria.
En sólo 10 años, el número de películas
certificadas en la India se ha duplicado. En 2009,
se produjeron 1279 películas: en 2019 hablamos
de 2412. Además, las películas han mejorado
mucho tanto en calidad como en presupuesto.
Todo esto también significa que ahora es
rentable producir películas en otros idiomas
regionales más minoritarios como el Nagamese,
el Manipuri o el Chhattisgarhi.
Mientras los idiomas regionales siguen
siendo muy importantes, las películas en Hindi
están ganando cada vez más cuota de mercado. En
2009, las películas de Bollywood suponían el
18% de toda la producción nacional y el 19% de
los ingresos. Una década más tarde, suponen el
21% de la producción. En términos económicos,
Bollywood es, hoy en día, el 40% de los ingresos
totales del cine, el resto de idiomas regionales
suponen el 47% y sólo el 13% corresponde al cine
internacional, donde se encuentra Estados Unidos.
Y aquí viene la pregunta ¿Por qué Hollywood no
puede competir con el cine Indio en la India? La
respuesta es compleja, pero os la vamos a dar.
La primera razón es… ¡La censura!
Tanto las películas internacionales como las
películas indias tienen que pasar por los filtros
de censura. Pero, a diferencia de otros países,
la censura India es totalmente impredecible ¿Por
qué? Porque depende del gobierno de turno. Es
decir, que las reglas pueden cambiar cada 4 años.
Por ejemplo, hubo una época donde el sexo estaba
prohibido. Cada vez que había una escena erótica,
aparecían flores en la pantalla ¿Os acordáis de
esa escena del Titanic donde aparece Kate Winslet
desnuda? Pues los Indios no la pudieron ver.
Ahora, sin embargo, las reglas están más centradas
en asuntos de geopolítica. Eso explica que, en
2018, todas las escenas donde sale un mapa de
Kachemira en Misión Imposible fueran censuradas.
Por supuesto, si eres un productor de Bollywood,
te aseguras de que tus películas no tengan
escenas censurables. Pero muchas películas
de Hollywood terminan proyectándose sin muchas
escenas que son cruciales para entender la trama.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque
esta no es la única razón!
En la mayor parte de los países, incluído España,
las entradas de cine tienen el mismo precio,
independientemente de la película que vayamos a
ver. En India es totalmente distinto. Los precios
de las entradas son dinámicos. Es decir,
que no pagas lo mismo si ves una película
extranjera que si ves una película local. Es
más, el precio de una entrada puede variar
dependiendo del asiento que escojas, la hora en
la que vayas a ver la película o incluso el mes.
¡Pero atentos, porque hay una
tercera razón! Como os hemos dicho,
en la India hay muchos idiomas regionales. Muchos
de ellos son muy distintos entre ellos. Es decir,
que si quieres entrar en el mercado indio
no basta con doblar tu película al Hindi:
tienes que doblarla a los 26 idiomas regionales.
En otras palabras, que sólo es rentable invertir
en doblaje para grandes superproducciones.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando ahora mismo:
si el cine Indio es tan popular… seguramente
será un negocio enorme ¿verdad? Pues lo cierto
es que no. Por ejemplo, en el año 2019, toda
la industria generó unos ingresos de 13.300
millones de dólares. Y diréis ¿Esto es mucho o
poco? Pues, por hacer una comparación, sólo la
última película de la saga “Los Vengadores” ha
generado unos ingresos de casi 2.800 millones de
dólares. Según varias estimaciones, el cine
Indio da trabajo a sólo 200.000 personas.
Y aquí es donde llega la parte más contraintuitiva
de esta historia. Seguramente muchos pensaríais
que a los Indios les encanta ir al cine
¿Verdad? Pues no exactamente. La India
tiene una ratio de 6,5 pantallas de cine
por cada millón de habitantes. Por supuesto,
este número varía dependiendo de la
región. Pero, para que os hagáis una idea,
en China tienen 23 pantallas por cada millón de
habitantes y en Estados Unidos hablamos de 126.
Además, la piratería es un problema muy
serio en la India. Se estima que genera
unas pérdidas en la industria de más de
260 millones de dólares al año. Además,
aunque las entradas de cine son cada vez más
caras, el precio sigue siendo mucho más bajo
que en otras partes del mundo. Por supuesto,
todos estos datos están cambiando a medida
que crecen las plataformas online de vídeo
bajo demanda como Netflix y tantas otras.
Ahora bien, las salas de cine no son la única vía
de ingresos del cine Indio. Si alguna vez habéis
visto una película de Bollywood, ya sabéis que
la música y los bailes son muy importantes. Y,
por eso, una parte muy importante del negocio
del cine viene de los derechos musicales. Ahí
es donde entran empresas como T-Series, Zee Music
o Sony Music. De hecho, muchas veces se utilizan
los ingresos de la música como capital semilla
para nuevas películas. Todo esto explica por qué
YouTube es tan importante para Bollywood: les
sirve para promocionar su música. Y, por eso,
el canal de T-Series es el canal más grande del
mundo ¡Más grande que el mismísimo PewDewPie!
Pero bueno, ya hemos hablado de la parte económica
de esta historia. Pero ahora vamos a ver el lado
político. Porque, creedme, hay un lado político
en esta historia. Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
DESDE BOLLYWOOD HACIA EL MUNDO
Os voy a hacer una pregunta ¿Habéis visto alguna
vez una película India? Lo más probable es que la
respuesta sea un rotundo “no”. Y por eso,
muchos pensaréis que el cine Indio está
pensado únicamente para el consumo doméstico
¿Verdad? ¡Error! ¡Craso error! Por ejemplo,
a los rusos les encanta el cine de Bollywood.
Durante los años 50, India y la Unión Soviética
compartían la misma aversión a Occidente. Y así
empezó una bonita amistad entre Bollywood y Rusia.
En el año 1951, DHARTI KE LAL fue la primera
película proyectada en salas soviéticas. Esta
película contaba la historia de la hambruna en
Bengala de 1943 y estaba producida por IPTA,
un grupo teatral de izquierdas. Incluso
en 1954 se llegó a hacer una producción
Indo-soviética llamada PARDES. Desde
entonces, más de 300 películas indias
se proyectaron en salas soviéticas… hasta
el fin del comunismo. Desde entonces,
la audiencia de estas películas ha
seguido creciendo y ahora se estima
que entre 20 millones y 60 millones de
rusos ven películas indias todos los años.
El romance de Rusia con KAJ KAPOOR continúa
hoy en día, 29 años después de su muerte.
Incluso hoy en día, en la Rusia de Putin, la
televisión estatal DOMASHNY ofrece películas
de Bollywood. La película AWARA, del actor RAK
KAPOOR, fue todo un éxito en los años 60 y todavía
hoy es un clásico entre los rusos. La clásica
película nostálgica que todo el mundo ha visto
alguna vez ¡Pero no sólo hablamos de Rusia!
Como sabéis, hay una enorme diáspora India
en todo el mundo. Y muchas películas están
dirigidas para ese público. Por ejemplo,
en los años 90, la película DILWALE DULHANIA LE
JAYENGE contaba la historia de una familia India
que vivía en Reino Unido. Esta película
fue tal exitazo que incluso recibió un
premio de la Autoridad de Turismo Británica por
promover el turismo en la isla. Incluso cuando
el mismísimo Barack Obama visitó la India, en
2015, intentó imitar un diálogo de esta película.
Sin embargo, la mayor estrella internacional
de Bollywood hoy en día es el actor SHAH
RUKH KHAN. Y creedme, este señor no es
famoso únicamente en la India. Atentos.
Las estrellas de Bollywood se dirigen a Marruecos
Todo un comité de estrellas
Indias, incluyendo Shah Rukh Khan,
fueron el Festival Internacional
de Cine de Marrakech y fueron
recibidos por montones de fans. Y en esa
ceremonia, el rey marroquí, Mohammed VI,
le dio una estrella de oro, que es una especie
de condecoración nacional, a Shah Rukh Khan.
Y ya sé lo que estará pensando alguno: si
seguís VisualPolitik desde hace tiempo,
ya sabéis que los musulmanes en la India son
una de las minorías más maltratadas del país.
Los Hinduistas y los Musulmanes no se llevan bien.
Sin embargo, cuando hablamos de cine, la historia
es totalmente distinta. En el mundo árabe hay
canales enteros como, por ejemplo, ZEE AFLAM,
que se dedican a retransmitir en exclusiva
películas de Bollywood. Es más… ¿Os acordáis
de ese actor del que os acabamos de hablar;
Shah Ruk Khan? Pues mirad donde está ahora.
Shah Rukh Kahn es nombrado como
embajador de la marca de Dubai
¡Pero esto no es todo! En Wikileaks se han
llegado a filtrar cables diplomáticos donde
Estados Unidos sugiere utilizar a actores Indios
en estrategias antiterroristas. Por lo visto,
las películas indias son muy conocidas en países
como Afganistán. Incluso durante los tiempos de
los Talibanes, existían redes de contrabando
de DVDs de Bollywood. Pero esperad un momento
porque todavía falta la guinda del pastel ¿Cuál
es el mercado emergente por antonomasia? ¡Exacto!
¡China! De nuevo, si sois veteranos seguidores de
VisualPolitik, ya sabéis que las relaciones entre
India y China son cada vez peores. Incluso
es frecuente ver pequeñas escaramuzas en la
frontera de China con la India. De eso os
hemos hablado ya en un vídeo que os dejo en
la descripción. Sin embargo, cuando hablamos
de cine, la historia es totalmente distinta.
Damal está cerca de lograr los 150
millones de dólares en la taquilla China
Dangal es un drama sobre lucha libre protagonizado
por el actor AAMIR KHAN. Se estrenó en nada menos
que 9000 salas de cine chinas. Este éxito se
debe, en parte, a que los productores hicieron
una enorme campaña de marketing en este país.
Unos años más tarde, la película SECRET SUPERSTAR
consiguió recaudar más dinero en China que
“El último Jedi”, de la saga de Star Wars.
En otras palabras, que el cine Indio
está compitiendo mano a mano con el
cine estadounidense en uno de los
mercados más importantes del mundo.
Así que ahora la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Veremos algún día películas indias dobladas
al inglés o al español? ¿Puede el cine indio
llegar a ser tan influyente como el cine
estadounidense? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis que,
en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribíos a este canal y
dadle a la campanita para no perderos ninguna
de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado
este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en
el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta pronto.